okay no offense to this creator
cause there's tons like her
but as somebody who's lived in Charleston for 13 years
not a born and raised local
but somebody who moved here before it had like
blown up on the map people moving here to pursue a like
Charleston influencer aesthetic are kind of ruining Charleston
don't mean to say that everybody who moves here is doing that
because a lot of people move here for a lot of different reasons
and it's blown up since Covid
but I will tell you
that the people who come here with a preconceived idea of what Charleston is
without also assimilating to like
some of the cultural nuances here make it less fun to be here
I moved here from New York
I was one of the only people that had moved here
all of my core friends were born and raised Charlestonians
and as someone new to the area
you had to learn how to assimilate
you assimilated into the culture
you talked to the grocery store checkout lady at the Piggly Wiggly
walk a little slower
you get used to the fact that we didn't have Doordash and Uber Eats
and all of these things that you're used to in a big city
there's a slowness and a charm about this city
that was so magical and so enchanting
I swear to god
as soon as travel and leisure got a hold of it and started posting it as like
the best small city in the United States
so many people moved here without taking the breath to become part of Charleston
they wanna video it they wanna get their outfit of the day
they wanna go to every hot restaurant
but they haven't really made friends with people who are locals here
you see it with businesses too
there's so many investor LED businesses that are moving to Charleston
that is pushing out the mom and pop shops
the chef owned restaurants
driving up rentals for storefronts
driving up housing costs
creating a massive problem with traffic and infrastructure
because we have built for just all of the new people
coming into these high density living situations
out any new roads or highways
Carlton just doesn't feel the same as it did 13 years ago
and my husband's been here like 25 years
and it just doesn't feel the same
this shouldn't be LA and don't get me wrong
there's a lot of positives to money and tourism coming into the city
absolutely because you used to not be able to have a freaking job here
unless you worked F&B but as someone who is also a newcomer to Charleston
but has lived here long enough to see the changes
and somebody who moved here and became like
extremely protective over the way of life here
and over the way people treat each other here
and just over the the sleepy
quiet town vibe that Charleston used to have
just kinda makes me sad Charleston does not cater to the locals anymore
in price in what they're selling and how they're selling it
and it's really unsustainable for the people who've made their life here